just how good is Disney's live-action
Mulan it's no longer as mysterious as
the Dark Side of the Moon the picture is
a hit with critics reviewers took to
social media to slather praise all over
mulan after its premiere Monday evening
there near unanimous chorus applauding
virtually every aspect of the production
we know what you're thinking but what
about the absence of those iconic songs
from the 1998 animated original how will
we contend with the fact that this Mulan
does not feature a tiny wisecracking
dragon voiced by Eddie Murphy as comic
relief according to the critics the
answer is simple while this Mulan
operates in the spirits of the original
it's also the unique vision of director
Nicky Cairo who has apparently knocked
it right the hell out of the park thanks
Disney's live-action remakes of their
classic properties have so far been a
bit of a mixed bag although that bag has
contains some insanely profitable films
last year's Dumbo Aladdin and the Lion
King were all met with mixed to poor
reviews even as audiences rewarded the
latter too with worldwide grosses well
north of 1 billion dollars if you caught
Milan's incredibly kick-ass full-length
trailer on Super Bowl Sunday though it
shouldn't surprise you to learn that the
professionals were blown away by the
movie star FA lose steely charismatic
presence K Rose assured direction and
the film's stunning fight choreography
were singled out for the most praised
and if you're among those fans who just
can't picture Mulan without the songs
you may be pleased to know that the
live-action adaptation didn't forget
them entirely Insider correspondent
Kristen hakuna made it clear that the
filmmakers acknowledge that the bold
choice to exclude the originals tunes
with leaf some fans wanting she wrote
Mulan is absolutely fantastic different
enough with great action scenes but with
the heart of the original film it
doesn't even matter that it's not a
musical if you're a fan of the animated
movie there are subtle nods to many of
the songs can't wait to see this again
Mashable entertainment editor Angie J
Han went even further writing Mulan is
the best of the Disney live-action
remake since Cinderella I didn't even
miss the songs finds new notes in a
story we already know while delivering
gorgeous action hearts and humor of
course there were also those critics who
had no particular connection to the
original film by and large they too
enjoy the heck out of Mulan / Mills
Peter serrate sorrow
I'm very surprised at how much I like
the live-action Millan movie it's so
majestic the action is thrilling it aims
for a level of sophistication and beauty
you don't expect that was never a huge
fan of the animated film I think I've
only seen it once you know we have to
work on your people skills
indeed Milan seems to be rather singular
among Disney's live-action remakes and
that it doesn't rely heavily on the stal
juh for the original to carry it instead
it appears to be a film seeking to carve
its own path with its bread and butter
being those killer action sequences
kevin pulao ii of yahoo entertainment
wrote I've seen Milan twice now and I
must say it's great easily Disney's best
live-action reboot I think it's also
Disney's first battle epic it is
beautiful and absorbing and rich and
empowering the cast is excellent in
Nicky Carroll's direction it's just
breathtaking that's such an expertly
choreographed battle epic would serve a
female empowerment narrative was also
not lost on critics the geekly shows
tinea lamb wrote Mulan is about a
warrior and that warrior is a legend
thank you from all the female warriors
that needed this kick a movie it's
different from the animated version and
I'll be proud to show my daughters this
film it's safe to say that offering up a
live-action Mulan so different from its
animated predecessor was a gamble of the
sort that Disney's not exactly known for
taking fortunately in this instance it
appears to have paid off big time we've
had a good feeling about this one from
the get-go and we're pleased that so far
the critics are proving us right let me
speak ancestors of two brave warrior
Mulan the loyal to brave the truth Mulan
is scheduled to hit the big screen on
March 27 2020 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]